hey folks and welcome to another
gamespot plays I'm your host for today
mr. Danny O'Dwyer and today I'm playing
probably the most interesting piece of
DLC that's come out for alien isolation
the super creepy first-person alien game
the Creative Assembly put out last year
at the sort of alien game that alien
fans were looking forward to playing for
a long time and I put a decent amount of
time into it I didn't do much of the
story stuff but what I really enjoyed
was the survivor mode at what we have
today is the third DLC pack for alien
isolation the first two were basically
map packs first survivor mode there was
three in the first one they did there
was three in the second one it was
corporate lockdown was the first one in
trauma and this is a brand new one
called safe haven and it has a
completely different mode it's similar
in style add to survivor mode but it's
called Salvage mode and it's actually
different in terms of I guess lengthen
beats in wash I have actually played it
yet so you're going to be sort of
joining me on my first experience having
a go of it so like all the other stuff
it's in the play game menu and alien
isolation obviously is a sort of the
main we go for survival mode is where I
spend most of the bulk of my time
playing this obviously if you've not
played the single-player this whole area
is super full of spoilers so be aware of
that before you get into it I got it
from what I know as well if you haven't
played it at this stage of Salvage mode
stuff doesn't necessarily touch on that
as much and obviously I have all 3 DLC
packs here downloaded as safe haven just
came out yesterday at time of recording
January thirteenth and you play as
Hughes in this one so I'm going to jump
straight into it each of the 10 stages
has a new task to complete and enemies
to contend with race against the clock
to improve your final score and post on
the leaderboards so as you can see on
the leaderboards there so for instance
would survive remote here some of the
folks on the top rankings have done it
in a rage ously fast times in fact evil
cookie in sauk has done it in the
impressive time of 0 minutes and 0
seconds so I'm not quite sure of it
and but when we go on to safe haven
we're talking about closer to an hour's
so apparently the timer on safe haven is
about two hours long and i'm gonna go
with hughes I think Hughes has access to
a bunch of interesting weapons earlier
on like the EMP which I believe
something I'm going to go to him and but
yeah you're basically playing this for I
think two hours is that the countdown so
it's a different experience to survivor
mode which is more of a like a dare I
say it speedrun like the first time you
do it you're basically just trying to
not be killed by the alien and but then
eventually you're like trying to do it
in a certain speed and basically take
off all the objectives and which is why
I enjoyed it so much because it's sort
of more snackable than the single player
campaign and also the single player
campaign sort of has peaks and valleys
like there's some really interesting
parts in it but then like if there was a
sort of a widespread criticism of it it
will be that there was a lot of downtime
and but I guess that's the balance you
have to strike with a game like alien
like they've done a fantastic job really
considering and it's a king of a bash in
super scared of one thing it's also
pretty pretty and playing this on the
PlayStation 4 for those who are
wondering obviously this DLC is
available on multiple platforms
including the pc which I imagine looks a
little bit better than this and also the
pc has not native I don't believe it has
oculus rift support and I've played here
in the office and it's quite wonderful
so one of the things about safe haven
here is that you basically get to choose
between going to two at different areas
for all of these missions the Gemini
systems and the Baucus apartments over
here and they've all got their own
little areas in them and different
objectives and so that's going to be our
first decision and the DLC here is that
actually there you start off in and not
so don't blame me so much of this game
looks very similar such is the
Sevastopol okay so Baucus apartments the
task for there is restart the generator
and I'll be familiar to anyone who's
done the corporate lockdown stuff in the
first DLC pack and the rewards blueprint
for the EMP and survival pack and
different for pipe bomb and survival
pack mmm I like the sound of pipe bombs
I'm go over this one then a our door
should open rather ominously okay let's
count let me get used to my my equipment
here again we've got a shotgun which I
should hopefully not be using too much
of it was my bolt bolt gun as well
obviously for those of you who have not
played alien isolation these are pieces
of equipment that you should probably
not be endeavouring to use very often
because they make lots of noise and what
your main tool is really this little
fella the motion sensor which obviously
helps you find if the alien is hiding
anywhere this is the point in these
demos where I always end up speaking a
lot less and like taking breaks between
sentences because like excuse my French
but this [ __ ] appears from everywhere
I lutely love the depth of field stuff
in this as well like and that's me
choosing to uh I'm looking at my little
my little sensor here then if I want to
see what's down there it's a little
modifier trigger right trigger inning or
left her go rather than you can see down
there obviously you can hide in things
it's basically using like this is not a
million miles away from what you were
used to or should be used to in survival
mode I guess the biggest difference is
instead of trying to run through a one
go this is a more sort of deliberate
longer process ultimately I guess it is
a speedrun as well but like it my first
time through any look through any
survivor mode level I'm gonna be taking
my sweet time now you can see in the top
left the time elapsed is ticking up
there so alright let's do a thing
come on
every time I do is I'm just waiting for
the alien to just pop up behind me good
job Open Sesame instance check to see if
alien is anywhere near us yeah we're
good so from what I understand of the
talking to folks about this expansion
pack before came out of this DLC or
other and the objectives themselves are
not as long as survival mode and
apparently also the general area is
about the size of two survivor mode and
maps so there's a decent amount of going
back and forth and and I guess you're
picking the sort of objectives yourself
based on what will be most used to you
going into the next area so it is
probably like oh really this probably is
one good way of doing this as their kind
of tends to be in surviving as well like
all the best versions the best speedruns
sort of become apparent as people start
posting up videos of them doing it fast
and
and I've also pretty sure that this
stuff happens that the alien is around I
didn't play from the start so a little
bit worried take all this early i will
take everything what's going on here is
it hey generator oh i just gonna make
noise isn't it oh ok i should probably
find a place to hide before i did this
but oh well
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
where she where is she where she is that
event
get in the banking in the bank an end of
a contender Bank attend event
great my motions ang is not working too
hot right now can't even see anything
right now don't make that much Knollys
Danny don't make that much noise I hate
when the controller vibrates I heard a
beep I can hear beep [ __ ] [ __ ]
there it is there it is oh all right
just as well because I [ __ ] cannot
see a thing all right
where's
it was on me you made that noise hey
dark is this [ __ ] all right I gotta see
if I could turn the gamma up because
this is ridiculous wow really we cranked
up already oh no sorry sorry you just
got it all right have I done yeah that's
a bit better okay okay that's better
that's more manageable [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] all right I'm gonna go down this
way maybe oh sweet love scrap
do you right outside the tunnel he
inside the tunnel oh [ __ ]
hey
is there another exit on this
get up here I have like I've absolutely
no idea where I'm what direction I'm
going in there which is the biggest
problem sure I'll take all those things
although I wouldn't mind actual
flamethrower possible scare away this
bugger ok I think I can go ahead here no
I really don't want to have to go the
same way I came I came in
and for those of you who've never play
in any of these survivor modes in the
past or for those who have and haven't
had to go of Salvage mode yet at Oh
[ __ ] hell Jesus Christ as I went to
say at dying is pretty frequent and the
other thing about this mode as well is
that you can choose to save whenever you
go back to the safe house and of course
I did not do so why I'm starting once
again from the start time number two
hours using these uh save stations but
they will take 2,500 points away from
your total time something to take into
account if you are in the speedrunning
community and let's go for the Bacchus
apartments just for the sake of mixing
it up although really I do know that
part of this possible so I should
probably stay there but whatever Bacchus
apartments
next time I turn on generator I'm gonna
make sure I know a good place to hide
that isn't a pipe that has no other exit
on it
maybe it's like the type of gaming I
find myself doing more now like I tend
to play a lot of games as opposed to
like I think before I worked in the game
surprised I'd spend time with what like
a lot more time with one game and but
for whatever reason if it's that or if
it said like I don't know perhaps he got
like a job that takes a lot of your time
or you got hobbies you know I'd spend
too much time playing games anymore and
I've really enjoyed at these parts of
alien isolation in fact if I had my way
in a perfect world I probably would have
just liked like almost like a cheaper
version of this game that was just the
survivor modes and because they've
definitely been my favorite aspect of
the game they're just super hardly to
pick up and have a little toy around
with you can kind of get really good at
one of them if you want like you can
attempt to master one or you can jump
between them like there's nothing
massively compact compelling about them
like as individual like that they're
kind of our what you see is what you get
but I really like what you get out of
them so that's why I find this really
interesting because this is kind of it's
almost like some sort of weird middle
ground between what the full game is and
wash the survivor mode stuff is like you
can imagine almost that in some sort of
like at one stage during the development
process that perhaps this just was what
80 isolation was it was like a two hour
time based
like you are the hunters but you have
all these objective thing I guess that's
what largely what isolation is anyway oh
I hate this bit okay I don't have an eye
on towards so i guess i'm gonna scan
this see oh you know what i might just
jump back into that pipe cuz at least i
know it's got an exit [ __ ] it [ __ ] it
see what happens cross your fingers
folks want to complete at least one
objective in this game before i get them
earlier
I'm like gritting my teeth right now
where is she where is she where she
he's not in front of the entrance I
don't think I don't think today if she's
outside there and she hears that door
like this little tunnel slide open I'm
pretty much bone hands here anymore [ __ ]
she is out there I'm for the door
I knew where that other pipe led I might
go for it but am I just destined to die
in a pipe
hey I'm gonna go for it [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
did you see me did you see me I think
she might have see me
get in this tunnel just get in any
tunnel get it wait [ __ ] hell
hey buddy
oh my god nice game [ __ ] game
ah
I don't like the ominous looking skull
on the shelf over there right [ __ ] go
close too close to any of these doors
and they open and make noise there's
like nowhere to hide here alright have
to go into this door lock
so when you see her move that fast a lot
of the time it's she's inside of air
duct not actually on your floor cuz this
thing doesn't like doesn't do height
very well and the only reason I'm not
going down to that tunnel down to the
right is that if I walk away from this
door it's going to close and then make
noise okay that's her going into a event
of some sort and I'm going to hope that
she doesn't hear that door or the store
[ __ ] this [ __ ] this oh [ __ ] hey what's
up bro [ __ ]
man
alright alright one more one more one
more reading that situation you want to
have a bigger weapon flamethrower for
instance guess the my wrong or does the
bolt gun I don't really think that's
gonna help that much either Matt yeah I
panicked and I just used this here a
lock and just hide in it the whole time
I guess eventually this is why you're
going to this is what you're trying to
get into perhaps alright alright let's
go back to the Gemini there must have
been a better way of doing that that I
was just being a tool about also see if
maybe mr. alien doesn't turn up madam
aenean doesn't turn up until you
actually did the generator let's see
does it may just be that i'm spending a
little bit too much time worrying about
and noise the survivor mode the aliens
pretty much on top of you straight away
the savage mode is a bunch of different
rules going on there we go little like
jogging that was in here that's the cans
of soda is the speedrun air this is that
so I'm not going into that pipe again I
could hide in here it makes less noise
the only other place i could see was
this exit here i guess i did not want to
do okay you gotta do I gotta restore
power before I can do that okay well I
coin in my pocket we could flip no I
gotta flip I grab I'm gonna flip my
phone all right screen sides I go in the
locker it's great inside locker Edith
very scientific right I'm straight into
the locker until alien passes and then
when she's gone I'm gonna jump in to
punch it
[ __ ] rocker
oh [ __ ] no get back in you idiot
I held too long but I solid snake style
any pretty lady pictures in here
I think we're okay
I think we're okay
although I can't point the stupid thing
to the left so who knows
don't make so much [ __ ] noise and
you're getting out you idiot oh yeah cut
like the ethanol we're gonna drink that
later oh [ __ ] [ __ ] no don't reload
panicking idiot why does he have to be
so loud what if to be so loud closing
locker
movin keep movin I see you
come back yep
you didn't see me
incident oh my god
the back ah feck ah alright well there
you go there's the adequately or in
adequately titled safe haven at the
latest DLC for creative Assembly's
wonderful alien isolation yeah I have
I've have enjoyed going through the same
process I've done with all of the
survivor modes which is basically get
killed a bunch figure out the best way
of not getting killed and then slowly
figuring out the fastest way of not
getting killed and I'm like I like the I
guess we didn't get so much of it today
sadly because I kind of getting murdered
and but I like the idea of building upon
your success and then picking up
different equipment and doing different
missions and whatnot and in that sort of
wider area it's basically to survival
map stuck together and with a little hub
area but it's an interesting sort of
concept I think it's good for a maybe if
you've got a night in you really want to
hammer through a speedrun or whatnot
obviously it's available to anyways pick
up the season pass i think the season
pass is 30 bucks on next-gen systems and
pc and you can buy them individually as
well uh pardon me would say that if you
got the first one with the three extra
survivor packs and you didn't pick up
the second one there's a bunch more dlc
coming face i think i might be five in
total but this one if you're going to
buy one individually i actually think is
probably a good show yeah so that's it
that's a safe haven for alien isolation
thanks very much for watching today on
gay.com and for continuing coverage of
all things alien and beyond as stay
tuned to gamespot see you next time
you